from Amazon spheres to adobe's grayscale
building with a colorful interior some
of the world's largest companies
redesigned their offices integrated
technology and modernized the
traditional office space we went inside
to explore the decisions behind the
design and how it suits each Brand's
work culture our first story is about
Samsung's futuristic headquarters a 300
million dollar office that has access to
the outdoors on every floor Samsung is
one of the world's largest tech
companies but it's had a low-key
presence in Silicon Valley until this
300 million dollar campus opened in
2015. let's check it out purple
[Music]
mango
this design is about connecting people
and the design started as really two
separate buildings and then we
ultimately landed on this idea of these
two-story bars that would connect the
building on both sides and really Define
this Courtyard space
[Music]
originally
this Courtyard in one of our initial and
one of our initial designs was actually
rectangular the curves weren't here it
actually it actually came together in
sort of hard edges we actually ran a
computational script and looked at what
a typical day would look like on a on an
office floor looking at how many
calories each employee might burn and
how many of their colleagues they might
see and what we found was was that by
studying that if we began to round these
corners and actually create two-story
spaces Behind These curved sections of
glass that improved people's visibility
and actually drew them out into those
spaces and allowed them a greater
opportunity for collaborations so how
many calories would I burn working at
Samsung every day probably just in the
course of a normal work day I have to
remember what the script said but it was
between seven and eight hundred
[Music]
does this space help with productivity
it does there are a couple things that
are happening here first of all you
notice that you're getting a view and
natural light from both sides of the
space which is important there's
research that's shown how natural light
and Views help people focus and process
information in a more effective way than
if they're in a more closed environment
[Music]
so right now we're in one of the main
workspaces in the building it's sort of
an open two-story design with the desks
all along the outside here and then a
main staircase behind me that connects
them the architect tells me that the
goal of this was to sort of get people
up out of their desks moving around and
then just also to be able to see people
and see which of their colleagues are
free so they could go have a
conversation
have you actually seen people connecting
and having these impromptu meetings or
is that a sort of goal that isn't
playing out in real time I think it was
a goal but I've actually seen it and
I've experienced it myself and so for
example I have lots of meetings all over
the building from any point during the
day and I'm always bumping into somebody
from another department somebody in my
organization then oh yeah by the way and
you sort of find yourself having these
by the way conversations and so I think
the design of the building really
facilitates people to get up and move
around a lot and then that's where you
have those those encounters yeah I've
definitely noticed there's a lot of
walking around I feel like I've even
done a fair amount of walking around I
think you can get your step count up to
about ten thousand without leaving the
building during the day
from here you can really get a good
sense of the building design you can see
the public area down below the first
floor of closed office spaces another
open-air walkway offices open air
walkway and then the top of the building
and really what you're seeing is the
office's commitment to getting people
outside with the public area below and
the open air floors here no Samsung
employee is more than one floor away
from being outside
we wanted people to get up out of their
desks and move and actually get out of
the building and and so rather than
having the the cafe actually inside of
the building we consciously pulled it
out across the public space
so rather than this being kind of a more
of a typical cafeteria we wanted to give
it and I have it more of a dynamic and
lighter feel and it goes back to that
whole idea of encouraging people to come
and spend time here and potentially
engage
other workers that they might not
normally see during the course of the
Earth Day employees can choose from
around a dozen types of global Cuisine
prepared fresh each day and then there's
the other perks on campus tennis courts
full court basketball a gym a garden
massage rooms a coffee shop and the
Chill Zone
[Music]
so this is the Chill Zone there are
foosball tables ping pong tables arcade
games sports playing on the wall back
there basically there's a lot of not
work happening in this room
it's pretty fun
having this right here in the heart of
Silicon Valley allows us to compete very
well in that in that war for talent and
is it working absolutely I think if you
look at some of the glass door scores
and other metrics like that I think
we've made some some great strides in
the last couple of years in terms of
having a very very open and
collaborative environment that we've
created here for our employees do you
think other companies in Silicon Valley
other Tech firms will create spaces that
are more like this
I think they're going to have to because
the younger
it's a creative talent that these
companies are targeting that they need
basically to survive are expecting
spaces like this I think companies will
if they want to continue to attract that
talent and stay ahead of the curve
they're going to need to consider you
know ideas like this and in spaces like
this
oh and also there are these things
called nap pods
I gotta try one out
I guess I kind of want to go to sleep
oh
not bad
at linkedin's Flagship office space
there are more than 75 different types
of seating this feels like a spot for
maybe a really quick call or just
answering a couple of emails work
or NBA Jam yeah this is your space yeah
this is my space and that's your space
many of these seats were actually meant
to be desks so I think during our
initial plans we had just standard desks
in this space with traditional
conference rooms and huddle rooms but
the pandemic changed that how much of
what we're seeing in this space is new
as a result of the pandemic 100 of it
this recently open space is designed for
hybrid work a model that has emerged as
the leading choice for LinkedIn and
others with 42 percent of people with
remote capable jobs working partly at
home according to a February Gallup poll
so what does a hybrid office look like I
toured building one with the Project's
leaders to find out and to get a glimpse
into what could be the future of
workplace design
building one is the new Hub of
linkedin's campus in Silicon Valley it
has six floors roughly 239 000 square
feet and room for about 1500 employees
prior to the pandemic when we looked at
this building really at that point the
main goal was fitting as many people as
we could in this space the original
floor plans called for 1080 individual
workstations the thinking was what
employee one desk once we were sent home
during the pandemic you know a lot of
that changed and much of what we were
trying to solve for before the pandemic
was not the same
thing that we were looking at at that
moment so with the help of its design
Partners at nbbj LinkedIn retooled the
space cutting the number of desks in
half to 569 workstations and adding
dozens of new non-traditional seating
setups what did you and Linkedin learn
from the pandemic that would result in
the space that we're in right now I
think we really wanted to do a lot of
experimentation because we just didn't
know no one had a crystal ball about
what the future would actually be so we
wanted to provide as many variety of
spaces as possible
the variety starts right when employees
walk in
the design does away with a large Lobby
in favor of a cafe
[Music]
you fill the buzz there's people getting
coffee there's people moving throughout
the space the cafe spills into the first
of two areas LinkedIn calls its
co-working spaces think open
non-reserved seating the co-working area
on the second floor was added in the
redesign so we've got primary work
points here desks with monitors and
tall-backed boots with ottomans dot the
space that looking back at the original
design was once full of assigned
workstations so a space like this is
great for those like smaller time
periods where you might come in and like
work with your team and then go home and
do some Focus time and that's vice versa
yeah and that's okay with LinkedIn to to
come in for half the day and work at
home for half the day yeah linkedin's
approach is that we are leading with
trust
the idea is that we trust our employees
to make the decision that's going to be
best for them and their teams co-working
is open to anyone in the company for any
amount of time employees assigned to the
building who plan to work there all day
will likely move upstairs the concept
behind how the floors are planned is the
entry to the building is the most social
and the farther that you get into the
space it becomes more focused workers
sit in so-called neighborhoods or areas
assigned to their teams we call this the
living room neighborhoods are split
about half alternative workspaces and
half traditional desks those desks are
mostly here in the bag was this sort of
what the whole floor was meant to look
like before the pandemic it is what the
whole floor looked like before the
pandemic what led the decision to get
rid of desk space because we imagined
that not everyone is going to come to
work eight hours a day so rather than
fill the space with potentially empty
desks of which I still saw plenty new
furniture was added based on something
called the postures Matrix the postures
Matrix is about the amount of time that
we imagine a person would be working
doing a certain activity combined with
the amount of ergonomics to support that
so how long have I meant to spend at
this chair here so as a high table we
imagine that you spend less time
compared to a low standard tables so
this would this would be used maybe 30
to 60 Minutes LinkedIn employees in
building one don't have assigned desks
instead they can grab a seat anywhere in
their neighborhood but it's not quite
hot desking either as seats don't need
to be reserved even before the pandemic
our desk utilization was I think was
around 30 to 40 percent 30 to 40 percent
meaning that like
even though people might be in the
office all day they're at meetings
they're at lunch they might be sick
right or just not in the office and so
now we're really looking at what does
that desk utilization look like in a
hybrid world do you know what that is
yet no but in a hybrid office the
individual setup is arguably easier to
design for it's the conference room
that's tricky here LinkedIn is again
experimenting from conference rooms that
look like living rooms what we wanted to
do was to take away the formality of
meetings from off-site to on-site and
put people in a neutral position where
where if you are at home as a part of
the conversation you're feeling very
comfortable interacting with your
colleagues to conference rooms packed
with tech including cameras positioned
at table height that reframe to better
show the speaker so it makes it a little
bit more like you're sitting at the
table and cameras that help make the
physical digital when folks are actually
writing on on this on this whiteboard
typically what you would be doing is
writing like this and a camera would be
behind you shadowing you from other
people from seeing what it is that
you're actually able to see actually
what's going on this technology ghosts
you out so that people that are remote
can see what you're writing can we test
it let's do it all right
I'm standing in front of it now see
what's capturing yeah I see what you
mean so you have this new space with all
of these new bits of technology and
different types of seating is it meant
to encourage people to come back into
the office
um I think it's meant to
welcome people
if that's where they need to be but if
that person is going to do their best
work and have their best contributions
to their team while being remote that's
okay that flexibility may not be
possible for some companies and others
like Tesla simply aren't interested but
LinkedIn sees building one as a kind of
test one that others could learn from to
what extent is what we're seeing here in
linkedin's office the future of work
what we have is an awesome opportunity
to experiment and to see what happens
over time and that this is entirely
flexible space it might turn out that
what we need are more desks in the
future and that this could be changed
into that or it might turn into a
completely different model but the
experimentation and the observation is
really the key to seeing what the future
is
[Music]
we're here at adobe's headquarters in
Downtown San Jose and this grayscale
building behind me might not be what
you'd expect from the makers of
Photoshop but let's check out the inside
[Music]
Adobe built in San Jose HQ in 1994.
after 20 years it came time for a
redesign designer Natalie Engel said it
was in need of a more colorful update
you know when we first ventured to the
space it is exactly what you would
imagine
from the outside it was very Bank
institutional like sure and that's not
what tech is that's specifically not
what Adobe is
so when I walk in here as an employee
during the morning and the first thing I
see is this vibrant orange color what is
that doing for me it should have the
right amount of yellow in it actually to
have this happiness a vibrancy but not
too vibrant to agitate you and so we
really wanted especially after people
are stuck in traffic to come in here and
just feel refreshed and vibrant and
ready to start their day
color is more than Aesthetics in Adobe
it's their business so angles and Adobe
used color theory throughout the space
to think more scientifically about how
Hues and brightness levels Inspire work
so when you think about it from a
scientific perspective that orange
that's very much kind of an invitation
for Community what we find is we find
people working down here on their own
they're opting in it's a place that they
want to be it's been active since we've
opened it
Beyond fresh color angles designed a
variety of spaces to accommodate
different types of work before the
redesign Adobe had only closed office
spaces the focus then was on giving
Engineers the quiet space they needed
for work floors looked like this one
at work has shifted as Generations have
changed it became pretty obvious that
they needed to be together so that meant
opening office is up but Adobe isn't a
full open Office environment we really
want to create balanced workspace do you
have the right meeting rooms is there a
place where you can make phone calls
when you're not disturbing others a
workstation or a desk is actually about
task work that's why each floor also has
spaces for group and individual focused
work Adobe has these phone booths that
are dedicated to special moments in
photoshop's history this is 1990 the
year Photoshop was invented and they
actually have the first version
installed on this map right here let's
check it out suppose a Color Picker
doesn't really matter when you're
operating in grayscale
each Florida Dobie is different some
like this one were more experimental
tests to see what worked for employees
so now we're into this more open Office
environment yes I think something that's
fascinating about this floor is that
there are no offices while everything
everything in life is an experiment we
don't know exactly what's going to work
better for you that's going to work for
me and so there is a spirit of
innovation
what we're trying to do is be more
Innovative and to do that you have to
experiment more and you have to almost
create a culture in an environment where
you can feel that
in a modular room called lab 82 named
after the year Adobe was founded the
company tests ideas and workplace design
including how plants sounds colors and
scents can change a meeting
and what we're looking to do is identify
the best possible future ways of being
able to collaborate
and when something really worked Engels
and Adobe listened these booths are
really popular oh they're so they're so
popular that we had to come back in and
add this whole row
one of the most noticeable upgrades
Adobe made in the redesign was the
addition of two new cafes they went from
one to three
this face is their Cafe called palettes
it's Farm to Fork concept and it really
Harkens back to what this land was you
know this whole area was Orchards and so
we really wanted to give people a place
that recognized what the community was
appreciate it don't just brush it under
the rug
the cafe gets some of its produce from
the company-run garden located just
outside its stores we're able to grow
about 5 000 pounds of produce that we
use in our cafes and in our learning
kitchens and what's really great about
it is we have employees come and grow
their own produce here on site we bring
Master Gardeners to teach them different
things that they can grow and provide
them seats that they can take home and
grow on their own
Adobe wants employees to be healthy and
that means more than eating well in its
Wellness Center employees have access to
cardio machines weights classes and this
so Adobe has this thing called the Soma
dome which is basically a guided
meditation experience in this pink egg
try it out
I'm getting ocean waves
it's relaxing
foreign
adobe's redesign continues on some
floors but across the street the company
is more than doubling its capacity with
a new tower set to open in 2022. this is
the new office space going to look like
this space inside there will be a lot of
the essence of what's Happening Here but
also trying to think about how people
will be using devices differently how
they'll be commuting differently if you
design perfect space for now
for a tower that's going to open in 2022
you can guarantee that it's not going to
work sounds like the experimentation
will continue
[Music]
entering Marriott's new headquarters is
like walking into a hotel you checking
at the front desk grab a coffee and tap
your card to get inside where you'll
find a hotel room
well kind of we've got a little table a
bed a bench built out of foam core a
ledge built out of foam core this
mock-up room is here for testing Flex
seating areas here for collaboration and
amenities an additional sweetener to get
employees excited to come back to the
office it's some of the things that you
would see in a hotel just kind of some
of those ingredients of bringing people
together but just done in a very
different way the 600 million dollar
space represents Marriott's bet on the
future of the physical office question
is will it draw Marriott's hybrid
Workforce back I took a tour with the
Project's leaders to find out and
discover how Marriott's using the space
for work and experimentation
Marriott's new office located in
Bethesda Maryland is really a campus a
tower with 785 000 square feet of
workspace and a flagship hotel with 245
rooms including 13 that will be a little
different this particular room is going
to be a sample room for the Westin brand
so this is going to be a Sheridan room a
Moxie hotel room the courtyard room
Stephanie leonartz Marriott's president
was part of a small internal team that
helped develop the vision for the new
office in part by touring other office
spaces we went to tech companies out
west we went to other retailers to see
what they were doing I wonder were you
also drawing some inspiration from
Marriott's own properties we are experts
in hotel design we know how people are
living and working and traveling these
days and we took all of those insights
from our Core Business and put them into
this fabulous new corporate headquarters
and the hotel next door the hotel-like
design starts with the lobby it was a
way way for us to think about how do you
deconstruct what a Hospitality
experience is and then Infuse that with
a workplace and come out with a formula
that is very unique it speaks Marriott
but then it feels like you're going
somewhere different it's trying to
transport you somewhere the design does
this in one big way this video screen
how tall is it it's over 20 feet tall oh
my gosh and it wraps like 65 feet around
which is incredible but it also has some
more subtle knots to travel so the light
for instance is something that we
designed to queue for travel it's
literally topographic lines travel isn't
just a reference to Marriott's business
it's also how the company operates
Myriad estimates that even before the
pandemic a third of workers were on the
road
so for Jordan Goldstein and The
Architects at gunsler that meant
building in flexibility something that's
on display just off the lobby in a
three-story Atrium known as The Hub
what's the point of creating such a
flexible multi-use space like this why
not just close it off make it desks fit
more people in I think for you know
Marriott and also for us it was
recognizing that you know the way people
are going to be working it's not
prescriptive we want to give people
choice employees could sit here here or
even work here people really love these
especially on those days when it's not
so nice outside right you can still get
a walk and talk in X and you can even do
it in high heels if you want to yeah
up one floor before the more traditional
workspaces is this lab-like space which
holds a test kitchen bar and that
mock-up room we've drawn with a sharpie
where the mirror will be where the TV
will be and it's all to give you a sense
of what this room will feel like and we
can move this wall back six inches and
you can actually see that six inches can
make a big difference in terms of how a
hotel room could feel but to see how
guests actually experience a new room
design Marriott will use those 13 guest
rooms being built inside the hotel next
door we didn't have this in our old
building we had sample rooms in a
basement right and since it was in a
basement there wasn't natural light
there was fake windows and there wasn't
real plumbing and you certainly couldn't
see a hotel room right there was like a
movie set you couldn't you didn't say
overnight there but now with our new
corporate headquarters we can do things
we never could have done before
between the sample rooms and the lab
space Marriott has devoted more than 22
000 square feet of space to Innovation
that's balanced with 16 more traditional
work floors like this one just upstairs
there are 2842 workspaces most of those
are desks which aren't actually assigned
to employees instead the hotel company
uses the hoteling model what are you
doing in this space to give people some
level of privacy in some sense that they
have ownership over their world it's a
lot of differential spatial experiences
so you know if you look at where you and
I are now we're in the open right but we
walk a few feet this direction over here
we're in a different opportunity to pull
aside so the best way to combat the hard
parts of the open Office plan is to give
people other options give them Choice
yeah and that's just what Marriott did
when it tweaked the design during the
pandemic originally the workspace floors
looked like this mostly individual
workstations then 25 of those desks were
removed creating a floor plan that looks
like this with couches tables and booths
why take away that 25 percent of desks
and add these new spaces I think you
still do need in individual workstations
and private space right but much of the
work that's done in the hotel business
in the case of our company is
collaboration Marriott's office opened
to employees at a time when office use
is on the rise nationally workers are
returning to offices at the highest rate
since the pandemic began as coveted
infection numbers fall and companies
increasingly mandate in office time
Marriott however plans to stay hybrid as
people start to come back to the office
even in a hybrid environment I wonder
what role office design has to play in
getting them to come to work more it's a
catalyst for sure I deeply believe that
hybrid work makes a lot of sense and it
can be very successful but hybrid work
does mean that you are part of the time
working physically together when you
walk around if spaces aren't full and
people are working remote or traveling
will the investment in this new office
space still feel worth it because I'm in
the hotel in the travel business I
believe people need to be together
that's why everyone's traveling again
right and I think that's true in the
case of work as well so I'm very
confident that this building will be
full enough of the time to be well worth
the investment
[Music]
Cisco's revamped New York office is
packed with technology there's Tech that
tracks there's 5 000 individual data
points that are being constantly
collected and harvested in this facility
and Tech used for collaboration is there
any space in this office that doesn't
have a camera no there isn't Cisco's
smart office is both the Showcase of the
company's technology and an example of
how it sees the workplace evolving so
how does it look and more importantly
how does it work I took a tour with the
Project's leaders and popped into a few
meetings to find out
this goes 59 000 square foot office sits
in Midtown Manhattan and one Penn Plaza
exactly where it's been for the last 17
years
but in the last two it's undergone an 18
million dollar Tech driven redesign this
is one of the few projects where
technology was really at the very
beginning and pervasive throughout the
entire process in this space the screens
cameras and sensors came before the
lighting and Furniture which was a new
process for both Gensler and Cisco we
really think technology is going to be
at the heart of how people design
buildings moving forward so we started
it with that layer to see this Tech all
you have to do is look up the ceiling is
littered with tech Each of which doing
more than it might appear it's not hard
to miss this camera what does this
camera do actually this was a Meraki
security camera and obviously it's
recording people coming in and out of
the floor but it's also got a trip wire
built in we can actually count people as
they come in and decrement as they leave
so at any given time we know that the
overall occupancy of the floor but to
know where people are after they enter
the office Cisco uses its wireless
access points like this one it's
actually traffic tracking mobile devices
as a proxy for understanding occupancy
of space in people but it's also
tracking air quality temperature and
humidity is it tracking my mobile device
right yeah it's tracking a mobile device
it doesn't know it's you but it knows
there are two mobile devices here
because I have one in my pocket as well
leave the hallway to enter a meeting and
the camera is used to connect employees
on video call then pick up the count
tracking the number of participants in
the room
while employees may be anonymous this
type of tracking isn't common just one
percent of companies in a 2022 Gartner
poll have sensors that track foot
traffic 43 percent of companies say they
aren't tracking on-site attendance at
all our employees at all concerned about
the tracking that's possible in an
office where cameras count the number of
bodies in the space no I don't believe
they are and
where that is
at Cisco we don't have a set number of
days that we expect employees to be in
the office I think if we had different
expectations around being in the office
it may feel a little bit different but
because we don't I think they understand
that those insights allow us to make the
space the best that it can be for them
still these are Cisco products other
companies that purchase these systems
could use them for more specific
tracking or they could do as Cisco does
and feed the data here for employees to
see really what we have here is the
great ability to show employees space
availability red is obviously a space
that is booked and being used right now
or Amber is a space that's booked and
not being used and green is an available
space let's find a space that we can go
yeah so so here's the space right here
let's
we'll go to the space okay
let's hold that and that's going to give
us four minutes to get over there four
minutes because in this office space is
meant to be shared so rooms like the
ones lining this Hall aren't bookable
the red and green lights are your signal
see this is our room that we're going to
use yep
it's ad hoc spaces represent one of the
biggest changes to Cisco's space how
it's balanced take a look at Cisco's
floor plan these spaces are what Cisco
considers individual workspaces these
spaces are for teams in the past our
building was set up where seventy
percent of the space was targeted toward
individuals and 30 of the space was
targeted to our teams and we flipped
that that resulted in the 90
collaboration spaces seen here and left
just 50 individual desks I think this is
a new era and I think that when you want
to sit by yourself and get work done you
may not choose the office to do that
there are actually about 1700 employees
assigned to this office but Cisco
doesn't expect that they'll all be in on
the same day with hybrid here to stay
we're seeing so much more emphasis on
amenity spaces collaboration spaces
people are coming in to be with other
people the things that they can't do
when they're working at home things like
brainstorming on a whiteboard or meeting
in a 14-person room room like this one
are now the focus so what's really
interesting about this space is how the
space design how the furnishings and the
technology all come together they come
together because Cisco designed the
table to work specifically with the
camera at the other end from the
placement of the microphones to this
matte finish which helps reflect light
up onto the faces of the table most
noticeable though is the table's tapered
shape we shape the table to make sure
everybody has a line of sight on the
display all right and can see content
and we also have make sure that people
that are remote
that are joining us actually have line
of sight of everybody at the table right
because that person all the way at the
end is much further to the right than I
am so they should be able to see every
single face down the road that shape and
the exclusion of chairs on the screen
side is pervasive in Cisco space because
it says 98 of its meetings will have a
remote participant so who is this
conference room designed for is it
designed for the people who are here at
this table or is it designed for the
people who are signing in remotely when
we think about designing collaboration
spaces like this we spend as much time
if not more about worrying about the
remote participant we want to make sure
there's absolute digital equality
digital equality that's an idea that
Cisco stressed and something it thinks
it's hybrid Workforce needs something
that we have all experienced is
sometimes you're in a meeting and you're
having a hard time breaking in and
especially if you happen to be the only
one in the office or the only one
working remotely and here's where the
camera can help bring people or at least
their faces closer I tested it with
colleagues who work in two separate
offices are you seeing this this full
room are you seeing this whole table
no I'm seeing four trainers same I just
sent you a screen grab oh okay yeah so
it's really you're really only seeing
like my my side of the room
there is an argument to be made that
with all of Cisco's technology and the
ability to make every space into a
hybrid meeting space that the office
isn't really needed at all what would
you say to that well I think the at the
end of the day people will want to come
together but they're going to come
together for different reasons but for
those who'd rather stay home the tech is
here to support that and that's an
example that other companies may follow
so do you expect other companies you
work with to want to do Tech first
design second absolutely I mean so many
of our clients are interested in seeing
this space because of how this was built
I think anyone that's looking to build a
new space is going to think this way
people ask why spheres and there are
multiple reasons the Spheres are found
in nature we see in the Sun and the Moon
we see it in bubbles we see it even in
the people of the human eye
welcome to the Sears
let's go inside
the idea was that every Amazon employee
had the opportunity to get up from their
desk
to walk over to the Spheres and to come
into this kind of environment to think
and act differently than they would in
the inside an office building all of
these spaces are intended to create
different work environments
when we were designing the campus we
wanted to do something that was super
special not just for our employees and
their families but also for satellites I
started thinking about what's missing
from the urban environment and it's
generally a link to Nature and so we
wanted to link nature to the workplace
there's ample studies that show that
walking in the Park versus walking on a
city street results in you being less
stressed your cortisol levels are
reduced you can concentrate better
when we decided to do spheres we found
there were many really attractive
historical examples we liked all those
things but we wanted something organic
to reflect the purpose of the building
we found it in something called a
pentagonal hexacontehedron if you look
at this this example this is one of our
modules we call a Catalan it's an
elongated Pentagon in which there would
be 60 in order to create an entire
sphere
is I hold this this 3D print up of a
Catalan you'll see behind it the
large-scale version of it that's inside
the sphere structure as you look at the
building itself it's very hard to find
this module because it's intended to
look more like Vines growing or a spider
web
[Music]
the biggest challenge by far was how to
solve the environmental conditions here
traditional greenhouses as you know are
hot and humid we're trying to create an
environment for people during the day
and that it's for plants day and at
night
[Music]
through the 7th Avenue sphere we call it
the forest
a company can hire like the best people
and big companies do it all the time but
oftentimes they they kind of put these
people in little boxes right in cubicles
they're really not working at their
fullest potential
one of the things we wanted to do in the
Spheres was to create a place where they
could learn about something different be
curious about something different we
have Southeast Asian pitcher plants this
is another tropical Rhododendron which
is alocasia portiai slipper orchids from
Southeast Asia this is begonia size
morii from Vietnam this is one of my
favorite spots here in the sphere is
this behind me is one of the largest
indoor living walls in the country the
wall stands about 62 feet tall almost 50
feet wide it has something in the order
of 25 000 individual plants on it that's
a lot of green you know that we're
looking at
during the day we have that environment
that both of us like in at night the
temperature lowers to 55 degrees and the
humidity goes up to 85 percent or more
all the furniture all the equipment all
the finishes
are what we would normally design for
outdoor use in addition to the paths
through the forest there's also this
ring path from here you can see that we
look out to the city so you get the best
of both worlds
the canopy walk was another idea of
Amazon's we wanted to create the
opportunity for walking meetings because
we knew that if you are walking between
1.2 and 1.8 miles per hour you're at the
best speed at which to think
Ruby is our largest tree
she came in at 55 feet
it was a major task to get this tree in
because the Spheres had to be complete
when the trees came in because they had
to have the environment they needed to
thrive and live we had to create an
opening at the top of the building after
it was complete big enough to pull in a
tree like this
the next stop is The Birdcage The
Birdcage is a space for conferencing or
to just work alone it is a space that is
open like all the rest but we wanted to
give it some privacy so you'll notice
the vines that are growing up all the
way from the floor below up onto the
birdcage to provide that privacy screen
just one more floor
[Music]
this is our fourth floor it's under the
sky
you can look 360 Degrees around the city
it's kind of fun isn't it
majority of people that are being born
today will never see the Milky Way
because of light pollution and living in
cities we need to counteract that with
as many different good ideas as we can
the Spheres was one of those good ideas
to not only create alternative places to
work but to reintroduce nature into the
middle of the city street trees are not
enough we need to go farther